What about your past? What about your ancestry information are you, are you most
intrigued by, are you most interested in finding something out about? Hm, Ryan?
>> I think for me, it's just to see know
what different cultures or what different ethnic groups I spring
from, because the Philippines have been conquered by Spain, and
Spain ruled there for Four hundred years, and then the Japanese
invaded for a while, and then we were also part of
the United States for a while, and so just finding out
what different ethnic groups, what kind of, what kind of genetics
I have, in terms of where does my gene pool come from.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It's really, that's kind of in terms of the past for me and
so. The neanderthal thing is pretty cool too. Just kind of a interesting fact
[LAUGH].
>> It's not going to, it's not going to change
[CROSSTALK]
your, your identity at all?
>> No, it's just kind of of a thing, I just like, you know,
any, if I knew anyone who has it, oh, what's your percentage of neanderthal?
>>
[LAUGH].
[CROSSTALK].
>> Okay.
>> Cock, cocktail party conversation.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> Does it change your identity at all? If
you find this information Oh, I am going to
kagure and lets say you mentioned that you know
your mother is lighter skinned and may be is a
European and you know and my background is somewhere,
does that change any thing for how do you think
about yourself your family and, and how does it
impact that you are most interested in finding out about.
>> I think the change is what I
think about my family historically, in terms of what
happened at the time in the country, and where my ancestors were in order to
interact with people from another continent. I don't
think it changes how I think about my
grandmother, or each one of them as individuals. It just helps me build a story
as to where my people came from and that's what I would be most interested in.
>> So it's a more like sort of
completing a patchwork of, you know, your past and.
>> I, yes but, I mean, I could make it up but it's
[LAUGH].
>>
>> And I'd be very happy with that because clearly
it's not something that will change how I live my life.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It's more about The curiosity behind knowing where I came from with
almost, with more certainty than my made-up story in my head.
>> Sure.
>>
[CROSSTALK]
[NOISE]
So.
>> What about you, Sterling? Someone who, you know,
it doesn't, isn't familiar with their specific biological background?
>> I think for the, the deep historical part, the ancestry its
more of a curiosity I mean I can hypothesize you know, that I'm probably from
some mass up of European countries but it'll be interesting to know like
if there's specific ones that. More of my Genetics the great percentage of my
Genetics comes from So, that's start more a curiosity
but obliviously the biological relatives will have the more of an
impact and probably change, could change a few things in my life.